je me suis
c'est la place pie ix et la plus
florissante je lève les yeux bien
persuadé que les aston décote
un homme meurt et rejoint le ciel en
avion école tu nies mais pour certains
la mort est une aide moi c'est pas ya
vingt ans que j'aurais dû naître un
adulte le saccage en gage de palettes
rejet green pages de dial exemple sur
une plage de galets au plus profond du
bronze pour démarcher des heures qui
compte c'est l'émotion quitte à perdre
la notion du temps je traverserai chacun
voit pour tuer la boucle sur la route
comme jaguère mois soit tranquille
n'écoute pas ce qu'ils disent tu restes
toi mais pas victime car moynak on dit
que ces victimes que ça va voir et capo
cervo j'apprends nord comme dans l'es6
j'aime laisser place à l'impéritie par
faire c'était comme si je te faire
sammier troupeau je veux que tous bosse
à chaque jour que dieu fait sur la route
après midi laissait place à l'entrée vis
mais pour éviter la noyade soit huit
verres
j'vais une vie faite de voyages à défaut
de thé ont subi fort et uniforme mais ce
que la société voulait peut-être y lance
une mode développe t déjà mis nos fous
et fier je disais que j'aime et la
volupté répond-t-elle voulu dire ce que
je peux [ __ ] encore ici j'ai bien que
j'ai plus rien à faire a bien des
chances et se vante l'amour que manquera
au pair l'âge et alliés font un effort à
10,0 efforts chine où est formé puisque
je pense aux épaules et à 62 les
cagettes en bois sera quoi les lois sont
la voie souterraine l'oise entre les
glaces qui connaît pas le poids de la
micro l envers ces tendances montrent
qu'en tant que quand tu t'attaques à
plumes et olympique aux deux c'était
magique
je pourrais pas plonger dans toi tu
imagines tu dois d'agir après réflexion
pas de machine à remonter le temps
[Musique]
sur la pluie d'hier mais ses classes à
l'imprévisible
le nouveau sur chaque jour que dieu fait
sur la route la famille d'y laisser
place à la bbc
mais pour éviter la noyade soit 8 faire
le voyage mais chlorés puces arm crever
tu le serbe stands après ses yeux
révulsés r il aurait vu le ciel
cette fille est une personne manquera la
peau ou ce qu'il manque à ma forme et
tout ce qui manquera la première éco
fric mais quand est-ce qu'on adore
déclin suivent la parenthèse ne traite
pas de salle riches même si j'aimais
bien c'est pas une pas plat ou tiennent
pourtant je suis pas mentir est un
artiste à part entière aux et plus
fatigante des walkman à dire y'a quoi
mal croix de bois toujours j'ai pas mal
en pis les bras
non
la notion du bien et communaux 100 ch
même ses bons démontrait je n'ai trouvé
aucun algorithme qui part dans mes
rêveries fantasmagorique
là où la terre est plate et le ciel bleu
comme une orange
[Musique]
alors
je ne laissais pas ça
c'est parti
plus un pied trop court
on pose chaque jour que du feu
sur l'année
je blessé face à l'imprévisible
un voyage
miller
les fêtes voyage
sur la rue
être du voyage
manger
[Musique]
nouveau
chaque jour que dieu fait sur l'avant
[Musique]
et la droite
soit évident faire
je suis plus faite voyage
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]